welcome to this installment of fun with
algorithms
I am Tess I'm a developer at Microsoft
and I might be a little bit more excited
about algorithms than the average Joe I
hope you are too because
um that's going to mean we're going to
have fun for the next hour or so
um about two years ago actually this uh
this guy over here Dylan introduced me
to this site called Advent of code which
has like super fun
um algorithm puzzles throughout the and
the month of December and that led to a
series of events that led to me doing
competitive programming and a couple of
things like that but
um
yeah generally getting even more
interested in algorithms
I think they've gotten a little bit of a
bad rep as something that's only used
during interviews
because
um let's face it maybe not all of our
days look like this at least not mine I
wish they did I honestly wish they did
but
um they do look a little bit like this
like a lot of
pre-processing of data and things like
that and all of those build on the
algorithms that we're going to talk
about today but today we're going to
talk about a little bit more basic fun
algorithms so did I say they were fun I
hope you think they are too because
that's that's the reason I hope you're
here
so we're going to start off with and
we're going to go through a series of
like big blocks of algorithms that you
can use as the basis and then kind of
use them as Lego pieces to build up
bigger algorithms we're going to start
off with a game
and this game is I'm thinking about a
number between one and a hundred and
you're gonna guess which number it is
in the most optimal way so that you have
to perform the least guesses as possible
you with me
so what would your first guess be what
would your first optimal guest be anyone
50. everyone knows yeah
so 50 is definitely the optimal guess
why because it even it evenly divides
the problem space into two pieces so
when I say
um when you say 50 I say higher we've
already eliminated number 1 through 50
right
and then we can go through and follow up
with this and we say you know we divide
it again in the middle say 75 I say
higher 88 I say lower 81 higher 84
higher 86 and so on until we find like
the perfect match which is 85 in this
case that's the number I was thinking
about
now this took seven guesses this turns
out to be the maximum number of guesses
that you will ever have to guess if
someone is thinking about a number
between one and a hundred
but we'll get there in a second this
algorithm that we used kind of invented
or that we've known from when we were
children almost
it's an algorithm called binary search
and it's a very very powerful algorithm
that can be used in many ways
um why is it so powerful well if we
would have done what is called the
linear search of the data if you would
have said one and I would have said
higher and then two and then higher you
would have attached to ask me 86 times
or 85 times before I got the number
right right
in fact the worst case scenario you
would have had to to ask me a hundred
times
because this is something called an O of
n algorithm it's like whatever the
number space it is is the maximum number
of questions you have to ask me
however in the case of the binary search
way where we guessed 50 and then 75 and
everything we have to guess the maximum
number of seven because
um if we look at how we divide the space
and look at like 2 to the power of 6 is
64. to the to the power of 70 or 7 is
128. somewhere in between there like
seven or a life state number that will
will be the actual maximum number
um 664. but we can't guess 664 times so
we have to guess seven so this is our
maximum number of things
now we think okay so 7 versus 86 or
actually 100 computers are fast why do
we care this is
um I mean they can equally easily
process seven versus hundred but what if
it's a million
then it turns out that it's a difference
between a million
and log two of
um a million which is 20. and if it's 10
million it turns out the log 2 the the
maximum number of guesses I have to make
is 29. so 10 million versus 29 now we're
talking right so this matters in the big
scale when we have big
big numbers to guess from
so this binary search thing is something
that you can use in any kind of sorted
space like you want to see if a number
exists in a sorted array we do the same
thing
and we take the you know the lowest and
highest index we take somewhere in the
middle
and then we say is it lower or higher
slower so we now change our search space
and finally we end up quickly at the
right number
just like interesting but a little bit
boring
so now how can we apply this to some
really interesting problems like this
lead code problem and don't feel like
you have to read all this we're going to
go through this with pictures and things
um but this is a medium lead code
question already in the first five
minutes of of the talk
so we have
our friend Coco the monkey she likes
bananas surprise surprise and she gets a
pile or a number of piles of bananas
from her keepers at the zoo
um these piles contain some number of
bananas each
and they say we're going to be back in
eight hours and you need to eat the
bananas okay
now
she likes to savor her bananas so she
likes to eat them very very slowly but
fast enough that she can eat all of them
before the the guards come back
she also has another quirk
she'll only eat bananas from one pile at
a time so we can't just take you know
whatever the sum of the numbers and
divide it by
um by your hours
so let's say for example she eats at two
bananas per hour
then it will take her a total of 15
hours to eat a bananas right
clear so far
um if she were to eat at Three Bananas
per hour we can sum it up and we can
find out the chicken eat them in 10
hours still not good enough
or four
and now finally we get to a number this
is like the lowest number that we can
get to where she can eat the bananas
like this is the slowest speed where she
can eat a bananas and still
still get here
um
so this is us doing linear search
through the uh through the speeds
well it turns out that Coco is a little
bit out there
she has
um she'll get like up to 10 000 piles of
bananas
and each pile of bananas can contain a
billion bananas
that's bananas
um
I'm thinking like at this point this
might not be about cocoa and the bananas
this might be about you know running
tasks on Azure batch
but we'll keep it to the to the cocoa
and the bananas because that's a little
bit more fun
so how do we deal with this because now
if we go through this and we look at
this
how many actual operations do we have to
make here this is going to be horrendous
like every cut every sum that we're
doing we're summing over like a maximum
of 10 000 piles
and the maximum speed that we could
foresee is actually
at the maximum number of bananas in a
given pile because in this example if we
were to go anywhere over 11 bananas per
hour we could still only eat bananas we
could still only eat one of the pilots
in in one hour so
so we know that lowest is one the
highest is one billion
and we have to iterate over ten thousand
so if we would do it the normal way we
would end up with a potential of like 10
bazillion calculations I don't even know
how to how to write how to say that
number but ten thousand by a billion
but what if we did it with binary search
now it becomes a little bit interesting
so what we do here is this is summing up
the
um the hours over the piles
and then we use this binary search
pattern of
if we find the speed that's you know
that doesn't take us there we have to
increase the speed or if we found a
speed that's good enough then we know
that the speed that we're looking for is
between one and that number
so we can use the same technique that we
use when guessing the numbers to narrow
down
the speed that coca needs to use here
and this now takes us to what
it takes us to
um
a calculation of like a maximum
calculation of 10 000 by 29 versus 10
000 by actually it's going to be a lot
more because a billion would have been
it would be more than 29 sorry I
calculated that wrong but literally it
will be like a huge huge improvement
over like doing it the linear search way
so this is where binary search becomes
interesting when you have like when
you're looking through large spaces but
it doesn't have to be as boring as a
sort of array
you see in in the pictures that I've
used this o of something and I'm sure a
lot of you know what this is and that
this is called Big O notation
so I'm not going to go through a full
course of like what a Big O notation is
but Big O is a way for us to compare
algorithms compare is roughly compare
whether one algorithm is better than the
other yes by how many iterations we have
to make through the data
so if we have
a list of fruits
um and we go through the fruits you know
we have a loop that goes through the
fruit this is called oweven because it's
linearly
um related to the input size that will
that means that if we have a hundred
items we do 100 iterations if we have a
thousand items we do a thousand
iterations and so on
if we do a double loop it's going to be
N squared it's very easy to understand I
think
but this is very rough and this is
talking about like the worst case
scenario now if we do something like
this we just print fruit salad that has
nothing to do with the fruits in the in
the thing that's called a constant so
it's it's constant it's not related to
the the number of items in the list even
if we print like five things it doesn't
matter it's still constant because we
don't care about coefficients and things
like that
we already know that if this was a
sorted array and we wanted to binary
search through it we have log of n which
is
very useful
um would it be better if we sorted the
array and then did binary search if we
had a non-assorted array the answer is
no because sorting also takes a lot of
time in fact it takes more than you're
searching through
the array this is just for you to know
that even like built-ins have a cost
um
so yes for a comparison this is like
what you're looking for if you're
looking for an algorithm that performs a
log of n versus then to
basically if you find an algorithm that
is at n that's a pretty good algorithm
in most cases
if we did something like this if we want
to know if Peach is in fruit
then this is actually an O of n
operation we have to go through the
whole list to figure it out if we're
using a list
however is there something we can do
here
anyone
yeah using a set or a hash table or a
dictionary or anything like that we
would have a constant lookup so whenever
you have a situation where you want to
be able to quickly look something up
then using a set is million times better
than using a list especially if you have
a large list if you have a small list it
doesn't really matter
um which brings us to data structures
which is one of the biggest things to
look at when and like one of the biggest
choices that you can make when you want
to optimize something
so if we have a dictionary or a set that
has a constant lookup
meaning that they're super good for when
you want to throw something in and find
out if if an item is in the list or if
or sorry in the set or in the dictionary
however why don't we always use
dictionary Source sets
because dictionaries or sets don't allow
us to have an ordered number of elements
so a dictionary or set doesn't have an
order and oftentimes we want an order it
matters to us which one comes first and
last
it also doesn't allow us to have
duplicate items which is another reason
why we would have a list
and it requires us to have something
called hashable items which means
integers or strings or things like that
that we can create a hash off not an
object that is not something that we can
have in a dictionary
an array or a list can also become a
stack it it's in fact a stack by default
um
if we pop from the back I am I'm saying
this because oftentimes we want to have
something else where we want first in
first out situations and then we can use
a neighbor of the list which is called a
q or a double Eden ended queue
um or Heap and by the way the pop left
and pop right are usually a constant
operation as well or a heap where we can
get like the minimum or the maximum
value fairly cheap
um or we can do like a sorted array
which is quite expensive compared to
everything else because it needs to keep
sorted and therefore it also needs to
to do a lot of work to keep sorted and
then we have a very very special kind of
um data set or sorry data structure
that's called a graph and this brings us
into the next big set of algorithms and
and I think the ones that are my
favorite to be honest
so we've all we're only using graphs
somehow in in our applications I think
um one example of the graph might be
friends on Facebook
this is called an undirected graph
because we don't have sort of like if
I'm friends with you you're friends with
me there is no direction to this or or
at least there's two directions
basically it's it goes both ways
whereas for example if we have something
like a Twitter group of friends then
this is a directed graph because we
might all be following Beyonce but she
ain't following following none of us
well I don't know maybe someone in at
the top but not me she's not following
me
um so this is a directed graph
and we can also have a graph for example
in this case a graph of cities where the
nodes and these are called the nodes
um are the cities and then the roads are
the edges in the graph and this is a
special graph because it has weights so
the steps between two nodes are not
equal instead they have different
lengths and this is important for when
we go through and find like shortest
paths and things like that
and this one also has a cycle so
um here for example if someone says take
me from here to to here we might get
stuck in this cycle
um actually get stuck there forever if
we don't take care and and check our
like and remember what we visited and
things like that
um yes another set of
um weighted items so this is like a set
of tasks in this case and this is called
a disjoint set because it has like two
groups so not all of the items are
connected
and we can have other things that don't
look like graphs but there are graphs so
this is a typical thing that doesn't
look like graph but it's a graph where
every path that you can walk in this
maze is a node and every neighbor is
every other uh every other square that
you can get to is
um like has one connection between them
but you wouldn't necessarily build this
up and write like okay so there's
connection between zero zero and zero
one like those indices instead you would
kind of like figure that out on the Fly
and then you might have something like a
chess board with a horse where its
neighbors are not the neighboring
squares but
the other
squares that it can get to so this is
also a graph
um some special graphs trees
um
an even more special trees buying a
research trees so these are super useful
for example if we want to be able to
sort a set and quickly figure out when
something is slower or higher so in this
case we can see that everything to the
left of the eight is lower and
everything to the right of the eight is
higher than the eight
or if you see someone on Twitter it says
you're I'm not interested in algorithms
I've never used to try they might have
because a try is a very special tree
that's used when you do for example
asp.net routing so a try is is a tree
where you start typing something in in
this case and the only options that we
have are a or b
um those are the only valid starts of
our route
and then from if you've typed in a the
only valid next option is p else it's
not in your dictionary
and finally if you type in a p again
like it's listing it as a valid word so
this is like a valid path or a valid
dictionary word so this is a super super
quick data structure to use for these
kind of like pattern matching or or
route equation
and then a linked list is um
is another good one
so you might think okay so they look
good on paper but how do I actually you
know represent them in anything that's
useful for a computer
and one way of representing them is
through an edge list so this is used
listing the the edges that there is like
you know a Road between Arsenal and
Stockholm and one between Australia and
Copenhagen
um you could even add and don't worry
about like the kilometers they are not
correct I know that but uh I just drew
something super fast
um and then but you can put in an edge
list also the weight of the rows between
them
this is useful because it's very compact
but it's not useful for iterating
through and the graph in any way because
it's hard and it's costly to go through
and say what are the possible other
cities I can reach from Oslo for example
so then you build something called an
adjacency list
that looks like this so this is just
basically a dictionary
that has for every node which other
nodes that you can get to
and
um similarly if you want to add weight
you could do this
okay enough about data structures let's
get into some algorithms again
so one of the most important algorithms
when it comes to graphs and I will is
reiterate this graphs are like
everywhere you'll use them all the time
so it's quite
uh for me at least I think it's it's
quite interesting to know these graph
algorithms the first one is depth first
search I'm sure
Evol at some point written a depth first
search whether or not you know that it
was a depth first search so what we do
in this case is we go from the start and
then go to a neighbor or a child and
then we go to its child and its child
and each child and each child and so on
until we reach our goal so it's like you
go the Deep Way first this is a good way
of iterating through
through a graph and if you find a dead
end or or something you can then
backtrack to where
um where you found like a bend in the
road
we can quickly make this into another
maybe even more useful algorithm by
changing the stack
into a queue
so in this case first in
first out
um
I want to also mentioned that we're
keeping a list of visited nodes here
um ESO we don't end up doing a loop
but the breadth first search has a very
very nice Advantage so what it does is
instead of going deep child child child
it says I want to see
all your children all its children all
its children
and all their children
and the neat effect of this is that it
will quickly find the shortest way
the shortest path to your destination so
it will always find the shortest path to
your destination
and it's a very very easy to
conceptualize algorithm I think
so
if you ever have a situation where you
need to find like the shortest number of
steps or you know the shortest path or
whatever breath first search is your
friend especially
if you don't have weights
um
now you might have a variation of this
if you're trying to solve a maze like
like this one where you have a key that
you need to get to before or like so you
can unlock the door in this case you
just think about nodes not only as
coordinates
but s coordinates plus whether or not it
has the key or not
so every every square is actually two
nodes in this graph
and then finally if we have
um costs or if we have weights we'll
need to use other types of algorithms
I'm not going to go through these but
they're also
like Wikipedia
um a Wikipedia search away and and very
easy to implement jxtra and a star so
Jigster is a greedy algorithm that
quickly finds the the fastest or the
shortest path the least costly path from
one node to all other nodes
um a star is an algorithm similar to it
but that has some kind of heuristics so
in this case for for example for the
roads that might know that to go from
Stockholm to Copenhagen it needs to go
south
so it'll favor the roads that go south
for example so you you add in your own
um heuristics to figure that out so
that's the speed up or an optimization
of jigstra and then if you have negative
um if you have negative weights then you
need to use another algorithm like
Parliament forward
but let's have a look at
um
again this breath first or depth first
search and how we can use this for other
type of problems than the fastest path
or a shortest path
so in this case we want to know
um how many sets do we have or maybe the
the size of the sets and the way we do
this is we start off at one node
and we go through and do a full depth
first search to like until our queue is
empty and we put them in a visited set
so this now becomes one set next time we
look at another node this is already in
the visited set so we ignore it
this is already in the visit it says we
ignore it this is already in the visit
set we ignore it we get to a new one now
we have two
and this is like a very simple way to
use DFS to figure out how many groups we
have so this is something we can use for
example if we have a set of cities and
we want to know should we build a road
between them or should we
um you know have an airline route
between them to be able to connect and
get to all the different cities here
um another interesting base algorithm
for graphs is called Union find so Union
find Works in in the way that we start
off
and with all the nodes as separate so
even if they have connections we start
them out as separate and with themselves
as roots
and then we take one and we'll look at
its neighbors and then we say we try to
connect them so in this case we say that
these
zero oh sorry one and two now gets the
same root as zero and then we go through
it
um its neighbors and we do the same and
if this neighbor already turns out to be
a part of another set We join the set so
we change like the root of all the items
in the set this is um a good algorithm
for
sort of figuring out both how many sets
do you have and you can go through for
example like this table now at the
bottom and see you know quickly see how
many of the items have the root zero and
how many items have the root four
because that will tell you how big the
sets are so there are a lot of different
questions that will come up that will
basically come down to count the number
of sets or counter sizes of the sets
um and finally one final graph algorithm
is a topological sort so a topological
sort works like this let's say you have
a set of steps that you have to do in in
a recipe or a set of classes that you
have to do where this one is
prerequisite for this one
and we want to know in which order do
you have to take all these or in which
order do we have to take perform all
these tasks in order for this to work
out
so that's sort of like the question we
ask
and this one works like this we take any
of the notes that don't have any
neighbors
and we write them out
then we kill the links to them and find
out what nodes do now not have any
neighbors
will write them out
kill the links and then we take this
last one that didn't have any neighbors
and we'll write this out
and this now becomes a reverse
topological sort so you can see that all
of these algorithms are fairly intuitive
and simple once you start thinking about
it like in fact once you start doing
them a few times it's they become a lot
less
um wow the guy came up with topological
so now it makes total sense how you do
this once you start doing this
um okay so that was all about graphs now
we're going to go into another topic
that's one of the favorites of like
these Twitter people like well I haven't
used dynamic programming in any of my
coding well guess what you have because
dynamic programming is just another way
of saying caching
it is a fancy way of saying caching that
makes you feel like a little bit better
than other people but
nonetheless
um
the way dynamic programming works is
like this we have everyone knows what
Fibonacci is yeah okay
great so at some point you've made so
you've done some recursion
um
so the way Fibonacci works and then is
obviously you take the previous number
and the previous previous number sum
them up this becomes your number your
Fibonacci number
um and it looks like this and it's the
first recursion question you'll probably
ever get
now a little problem with Fibonacci is
that if you want to calculate Fibonacci
F5
and then you have to calculate
fibonaccio 4 and fibrinage of three
and then it goes like this and you'll
see that there is a lot of repeated
calculations in here
in fact if you go to fibonaccio 50
you'll have so many repeated
calculations that you can end up
spending a full day doing this before
you're calculating the number
so obviously we don't like repetition
um and the way we can get around this is
by caching these values and this is what
dynamic programming is
so we call this memoization because we
need another fancy word for caching
um so this is the original and this is
the memoized version
you know so the only thing we do is we
say hey have I seen this end before then
just take it out of the cache if not
and use it
now if we're doing this in Python
we can even just do this
like you put on a cache directive
obviously there is a memory trade-off
here like it's going to store all the
results in in memory but this is a very
useful way to even like in any apis you
might have or anything like that do you
save yourself a lot of computing if
you're doing a lot of repeated tasks
um
and um
there's another
another fancy word for this for doing
this slightly differently it's called
tabulation and in tabulation instead of
doing it sort of like the Cashway like
putting the cash directive and
everything what we do in status we're
doing the iterative way without
recursion but we start off with you know
creating a list of the things we know
and then adding on to the list like the
next number and the next number and the
next number
we can also optimize this a little bit
because we're now we're only using like
the last and next to last number but you
know the idea is anyways that you start
building up
um
a set of
a set of results
so let's use this in in a little bit
more interesting problem
um or we have a House robber so this is
again a medium lead code question
um and the way this works is the House
robber robs houses and he gets loot so
the first house here has two Loot and
then the second one has seven and so on
and he wants to maximum maximize the the
amount of stuff that he gets
um he has a caveat that he cannot Rob
two adjacent houses
because then they will call the police
or something
normal stuff like there's a lot of this
stuff going on in lead code questions
they have to say but I think that's also
what makes them a little bit fun
so one way we could solve this is Brute
Force we could say what are all the
combinations and I didn't have time to
write out all the combinations for five
so I wrote out all the combinations for
four
but I hope you kind of like stay with me
and understand
so now
one is I Rob the house serious I don't
drop the house so these are all the
combinations that we could take we can
exclude the ones that have adjacent
houses
that's fine and we can now sum up all
the um all the loot from all the houses
that we we picked
great
um this will take us
for a hundred houses
1.27 by 10 to the power of 32 operations
that's a little fresh I think so maybe
we can do better than that because
that's that's not really viable I don't
think so let's think about this a little
bit
um when we come to house number one we
have two choices
we can either rob it
and then we can't Rob until house two
or we can not rob it and then we can
robot house one
right ruin it so that means that
if we think about it our Max loot means
take the loot at zero
plus whatever Max loot from two on or
take the max loot at one
and this will be your maximum amount
and now if we look at this
doesn't this look a little bit like
Fibonacci
in fact very much like Fibonacci I would
say
so
um we can simply do some dynamic
programming on this and in fact if you
can turn anything into a recursive
function
that where where the input value like in
this case or the input values are
hashable you can use dynamic programming
to solve this
and remember when we had like the 127 to
the power like times 10 to the power 32.
this is a hundred for a hundred houses
instead
now that's a pretty nice and sweet
Improvement so even in your apis and
everything I think that that dynamic
programming and caching of this in this
way has
um has a place
now the last uh type of algorithms I
want to go through is a subset of
dynamic programming that are called
sliding windows and these are also super
common in
um especially like in competitive
programming and and Lead coding and
things but also kind of in real life
so we have an array and we want to find
out the maximum
sub array sum like if we take sub arrays
of size K let's say k is 4
um which
for a number sub array has the maximum
sum
so we can do this in a Brute Force way
like this
we take
a computer sum
um certain two
and we move one step forward compute the
sum one step forward compute the sum
and so on and so on right easy we know
how to do this
now can someone figure out where we have
an overlapping sub problem here
like where could we cache this
say what
yeah
exactly so you see here where there is a
lot of yellow that indicates that we're
doing that a lot of times like we're
calculating we're summing that up a lot
of times like you're saying
so
instead of n times K we can actually
speed this up a lot and especially if we
have a large large size of the sub array
so what we do is like this we get the
sum of the first one and then to get the
next one
we don't sum all the elements up but we
take the last sum and remove in this
case the one we left off
and add on the one we picked up right
so we go through this like this and
suddenly we've saved ourselves a lot of
time because now we have an algorithm
that's only going to be as many
operations as the size of the
of the array
super super common and this is like
fairly easy to understand because we
have a fixed size array that we're going
through but this is a very useful
technique for many many problems so
let's look at a problem where we can use
this and this is a grumpy bookstore
owner a classic to um to the lead code
problems it's like a little bit of a
story
um
this guy has some people coming into his
bookstore every minute there's a
different number of people sometimes
he's happy sometimes he's sad
when he's happy then the patrons are
happy and we want to maximize sort of
like the amount of happy people we have
so we can say these people will always
be happy they're
um they're happy because he's happy now
he has a trick that will make him happy
for a certain number of minutes we're
not judging we all kind of like can
figure out what what it is but we're not
judging
um
so let's say they can make him happy for
three minutes
uh and he needs to optimize when he uses
this happiness to maximize the
the number of happy patrons he's going
to have now sorry I'm I'm doing like an
Asher batch job right now so I'm
thinking a lot about Azure batch but
this would kind of equate to we have a
rebate for an hour when can we put in
that rebate you know to to make sure
we're we're cramming the most out of our
a rebate or something
but anyway so what do we do here
um
well we can
take away the ones that we're always
happy
and then we can make this into a maximum
sum problem right
because we have this now we can just
figure out like the same technique that
we used
last time to just figure out which sub
array or which
um which window will make us happiest
using the exact same technique means
different storyline
cool so that's with a fixed window
and we're going to take two more one
um
with um with a window that's
um growing and shrinking so in this case
we have Amy she likes fruit she puts
fruits into baskets she goes around and
nurtured like in she can pick and like
she picks from every single tree but she
has this limitation where she can only
have two types of fruits in her basket
at the same time
I don't know she's picky like that
so the question is how many fruits can
she pick maximum
so the way you would go through this is
in a similar way where we go through
we start off
um with one apple
we expand the window until we reach a
point
where our premise is not valid anymore
so in this case we have three fruits in
our basket so this is not a valid window
instead we go through and Shrink until
our window is valid
and we expand it until it's invalid and
Shrink until it's valid again and we
just calculate like the maximum
and this is again an O of n of something
that can be like a very very very tricky
problem otherwise to to figure out where
we would have to go through you know
like all the combinations of pick this
pick that
um finally
the last one I want to talk about is
like a two-pointer
algorithm which is also a sliding window
thing
so in this case we have these walls and
we have water and our goal is to
maximize the amount of water that we can
we can have in this container
and the walls
um you see the First wall is like one
meter high
and the last wall is seven meters high
but we can only have water until like
the lowest wall That's otherwise it will
fill lower
um so question is which walls should we
use to maximize the uh the amount of
water we can use
now we can start off like this we know
that the the widest we can make it is
this and this turns out to be you know
give us like one by eight
um square meters or Square cubic meters
maybe of water and depending on
how deep I guess um the only way we can
make this any better
is if we make it higher right
yeah and the only way we can make it any
higher is if we move in you know like if
we
um instead of this we move in to the
next one that's actually making it
higher so now we have
seven by seven which is 49 and the only
way we could possibly make this better
is by moving the other one in now it
turned out it didn't make it better but
that was the only way we could possibly
have made it better right
and then in this last set the only way
we can make it better is again taking
the lowest one
and and finding like a better option for
it
um and this is like a very simple way
now to wait again our event to figure
out what the the water is so
um
some of these might think might come to
you in my I would come in and say well
how did you figure that out well yeah
it's not like totally obvious that you
should do this but if you've had if
you've seen enough problems and you
you've seen enough sort of like
different kind of variations you can
then use those and put them together so
um before we leave I want to kind of
like quickly talk about how I think
about algorithms and how I think about
coming upward with these weird Solutions
so
the first thing that that I do is I ask
a lot of questions I ask a lot of
questions about the problem and
obviously when when we have a lead code
problem or like a competition problem
the only information that's there is is
whatever information is written in the
text but there is usually a lot of
information there a lot of information
about like how many piles and and you
know what what the different things are
so and and also ask yourself questions
like do I need to actually simulate and
know all the paths in the graph
or do I just need to know sort of like
the number of paths because those two
are two completely different questions
one might be one where you find a
pattern and you can answer it and one
might be where you have to go through
and do a lot of work they're completely
different
and then
the limits so the limits for example if
you see something like 10 million or
like 10 billion
um
um bananas you know it's going to be a
binary search problem there is no way
you can create an algorithm that will
like effectively go through 10 billion
bananas
um
and then I like to grock the problem so
I can find another word for G I'm sorry
um but what I mean by this is like I'm
trying to be the algorithm I I draw a
lot on paper like I draw all the
examples I can in all the different ways
I can I try to sort of like mentally
think how do I in the small cases
actually solve the problem
if I go through and like what do I do
when I when I think like do I
automatically pick the highest number
for example then I need to figure out
how to pick the highest number these
kind of things
and then usually when you draw them out
and when you kind of like gone through a
lot of examples you get like this oh my
God yeah I understand like there is like
this key moment in time when you realize
that yeah the only way to make this
water any higher is by you know
increasing the lowest wall
then I try to reduce
um the problem into its core pieces
which might be okay so first I need to
sort the array for this to work or and
then I need to find out like the highest
number in 92
do X Y and Z and only then do I start to
implement I found like in the beginning
when I was doing especially when I was
doing
competitions I would go through and I
would immediately sit down and code and
it would take me so long because I
didn't have like I wasn't actually
thinking through the problem before I
I started and and the same thing
actually goes for when I'm at work like
oftentimes I find that like if I code
fast without you know because I think oh
this is an easy problem I'll
at least started like I'll end up
spending a lot of time on the back end
because I didn't design it first
and and then adding tests so for example
like for especially for these
competitions they usually have a bunch
of test cases and it's very useful to
just add in
you know
um like a few tests so you can kind of
like iterate over a given like a number
of solutions and see if it is still uh
passing all those tests
and then you go around and be happy and
then
what I usually do is I go through a lot
of other people's Solutions afterwards
to figure out how could I have done this
even better or what other options would
I could I have
um taken or or even tried to limit
myself a little bit more what if I
didn't have a chance to sort the array
what if I what if I can't do this
um
so that's how I go about and kind of
like coming up with an algorithm
um and
just for sort of like what what can you
do from here
um I've talked about lead code a lot
lead code and there's a lot of sites
like this so there's like code Forge and
a lot of these um different algorithm
sites that give you an algorithm a day
to to work on or or like have these
um a lot of interesting problems with
interesting like with uh where you can
actually type in code and then get it
tested like so it runs through all their
tests and everything and you can also go
in here and
and do competitions and competitions on
lead code for example they are on a
weekly basis they have competition in
U.S time zone and then bi-weekly they
have a European Time Zone competition
and no one else is going to know if you
enter or if you end up last or or
whatever it's a one and a half hour of
your time in your private home on your
private you know like on your computer
who cares where you end up you know but
for me it's like a fun way to see if I'm
improving or not and then
um yeah this is Dylan's moment because I
think this side whether it's Christmas
or not this is a fantastic site so this
is advent of code
um and in December every year
and this guy Eric puts up like two
challenges per day
um
with a lot of fun backstories of needs
to solve algorithm problems so if you
don't want to do it the whole year then
at least in December have some fun
and if you're more inclined to do math
there is a project Euler for
for math questions
um
but yeah
that was a lot of algorithms in one hour
so
um we have about 10 minutes or so
um before I have to give up the mic so
if you have any questions I'm here
but thank you so much for coming